[Musique]
comme nous le faisons depuis le début de
la crise peut vivre nous travaillons
pour plus de clarté et plus d'efficacité
et pour faire en sorte qu' on ne déroge
pas à nos libertés individuelles à nos
libertés publiques sauf exceptions
dûment motivée pour un motif médical
traduction pour ce texte premièrement
abrogation abrogation de poids avant
bien sûr de tous les textes qu'on
appelait deux ans pour leur
rétablissement
en fait de l'état des lois d'avant le
coc vide plus de possibilités aux films
plus de possibilité de couvre feu plus
de possibilité de pass
sanitaire de passes vaccinale pour aller
au restaurant cinéma cafés boîtes de
nuit tout ça disparaît le gouvernement
avait oublié de le faire du coup les
joueurs étaient soupçonnés je prends
juste titre parce qu'il disait vous avez
laissé dans les textes les pouvoirs
exceptionnels même s'ils sont plus
appliquées à partir du 31 juillet vous
pourriez les rétablir eh bien nous on ne
pourra pas les rétablir c'est ce que
j'ai proposé la commission des lois et
qu'elle a décidé deuxième
protection
pour les voyages
si un jour
ici les janvier prochain apparaît
invariants écovie extrêmement dangereux
alors on pourra dans le pays où est
apparu demandé aux voyageurs qui
viennent en france
d'avoir un test négatif
pour retarder le plus possible la
contamination des françaises de
protection frontières protection aussi
dans un cas particulier pour nos autres
maires si on voit que l'épidémie flanc
quelque part entre mer
et que le système hospitalier saturés
alors on pourra dire les vols de
l'hexagone vers l'outre-mer ne pourront
plus être utilisé par des gens qui n'ont
pas un test négatif ça c'est très
important et puis comme il ya un
règlement européen qui marche jusqu'en
janvier jusqu'en juin
2020 tu 3 et que n'importe quel pays
européen peut exiger d'un français
qu'ils aient
une vaccination à jour un certificat de
rétablissement ou un test négatif alors
il faut qu'il puisse avoir son
smartphone la preuve de test négatif il
faut donc que avec le consentement de la
personne le laboratoire d'analysé puisse
enregistrer l'information pour que en
bout de chaîne et puis cette montre est
dans l'avion marc le mans ou à l'arrivée
dans un pays d'europe qui exigerait pour
une raison ou une autre il a le droit de
le faire
jusqu'au 30 juin prochain
une preuve que la personne ne présente
pas de risque élevé de contaminer des
habitants de ce pays faciliter les
voyages des français ça a été notre
attention c'est le bon sens et puis
enfin on a dit attention pour les
personnels non vaccinés qui ont été
suspendus faudra bien un jour qui
reviennent au travail eh bien nous
demandons à la haute autorité de santé
de se prononcer sur la nécessité de
maintenir ou pas l'obligation vaccinale
possible belle mais le jour où elle se
sera prononcé éventuellement saisi par
le parlement
et où elle dira c'est plus nécessaire
alors ré intégration automatique
immédiat tandis qu'actuellement le
gouvernement peut faire ce qu'il veut
bien nous réduisons sa liberté d'action
en dix ans il ya plus de raisons
médicales alors il faut réintégrer
personnes seulement ce jour là qui n'est
peut-être pas venue d'elle mais nous
avons voulu la clarté si vous voyez tout
ça ce sont des règles simples claires
mais ce qui est en heureux eux mêmes
c'est que aujourd'hui c'est la liberté
retrouvée sur tout le territoire
national plus de contraintes d'aucune
sorte et plus de possibilités pour le
gouvernement de mettre en place de
nouvelles contre
[Musique]